>>> SO THIS MORNING MORNING JEREMY
RENNER IS SPEAKING OUT OF HIS
SNOW PLOW ACCIDENT.
HE POSTED THIS ON INSTAGRAM
THANKING FANS FOR KIND WORDS.
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE SAID THE
ACTOR WAS HELPING A FAMILY
MEMBER NEAR RENO, NEVADA, WHEN
HIS OWN SNOW PLOW WHICH WEIGHS
MORE THAN 14,000 POUNDS RAN OVER
HIM.
THE SHERIFF JOINS US NOW WHOSE
DEPUTIES RESPONDED TO THE
EMERGENCY.
WE'RE SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH THIS
ACCIDENT SCENE?
WHEN YOU AND YOUR TEAM ARRIVED,
WHAT WAS HAPPENING?
>> APPROXIMATELY 8:55 WE
RECEIVED A CALL TO 911 OF A SNOW
PLOW VERSUS PEDESTRIAN.
FOR US, WE JUST GOT THAT MAJOR
STORM ON THE WEST COAST.
THERE WAS ABOUT THREE FEET OF
SNOW AND THE HIGHWAY GOING UP
WAS CLOSED.
WHEN WE GOT THERE, WHAT WE SAW
WAS MR. RENNER AND HIS SNOW CAT.
HE HAD BEEN PLOWING HIS
NEIGHBOR, HIS PRIVATE ROAD.
HE UNSTUCK ONE OF HIS FAMILY
MEMBERS AND HE NOTICED THE
PISTON BULLY STARTED TO MOVE.
HE WENT TO GO BACK INTO THE SNOW
PLOW TO STOP IT.
A FAMILY MEMBER AND WITNESSES
SAW HIM GET INTO THE CAB AND
THEN HE DISAPPEARS.
LATER HE'S FOUND ON THE MIDDLE
OF THE ROAD AS THE SNOW PLOW
PASSED HIM AND RAN HIM OVER.
THE FAMILY MEMBER QUICKLY RAN TO
A NEIGHBOR'S HOUSE.
ASKED FOR HELP.
THOSE NEIGHBORS CAME OUT WITH
SOME TOWELS AND THEN FIRE FROM
THE FIRE PROTECTION CAME DOWN
AND WE CARE FLIGHTED HIM.
HE WAS SPEAKING WHEN OUR
DEPUTIES ARRIVED ON SCENE.
FOR WHAT JUST OCCURRED, HE WAS
IN GOOD SPIRITS.
>> WHAT WAS HE SAYING?
>> YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T GET WHAT
HE WAS SAYING TO THE DEPUTIES OR
THE FIRE, BUT I KNOW HE WAS
CONVERSING WITH THEM WHEN I
TALKED TO THEM.
IF I HAD TO ASSUME, HE WAS
PROBABLY IN A BIT OF SHOCK, BUT
HE WAS AWAKE AND SPEAKING TO
THEM.
>> ONE THING I LOVE ABOUT --
THAT I LEARNED ABOUT HIM SINCE
THIS HAPPENED IS WHAT A BIG PART
HE IS AND BIG FAN HE IS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
HE'S CALLED A RENO-KNIGHT.
HE'S SUCH AN ADVOCATE.
>> HE IS.
HE'S ONE OF OUR HONORARY
DEPUTIES AT THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
AND HE HELPS US DO SHOP WITH A
SHERIFF WHERE THEY DONATE
$50,000.
HE'S ONE OF THOSE MEMBERS.
HE DOES A LOT FOR THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN I TOOK OFFICE IN 2019, HE
SHOWED UP FOR SHOP WITH A
SHERIFF.
HE SIGNED AUTOGRAPHS, SHOPPED
WITH KIDS.
WHAT I TRULY ENJOY ABOUT
MR. RENNER, A LOT OF TIMES HE
DOES IT AND NO ONE KNOWS.
IT'S OUT OF THE KINDNESS OF HIS
HEART HE WANTS TO MAKE AN
IMPACT.
WE'RE GLAD HE'S OKAY AND ON A
SPEEDY RECOVERY.
HE LOVES OUR COMMUNITY.
>> IF NOT FOR THAT CUSHION OF
SNOW, THERE WAS A BIG CUSHION OF
SNOW THERE AND I'M SURE THAT
HELPED.
AM I WRONG?
>> IT DID.
IT WAS JUST ONE OF THOSE TRAGIC
EVENTS.
THAT'S WHY WE DID THE PRESS
CONFERENCE YESTERDAY BECAUSE
THERE WAS A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION.
IT WAS JUST A TRAGIC ACCIDENT.
THANK GOODNESS EVERYONE WAS
WATCHING OUT FOR HIM AND HE'S ON
THE MEND.
>> AMEN.
>> THANK YOU, SHERIFF.
>> THANK YOU GUYS.
HAVE A GREAT DAY.
>> TAKE CARE.